[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 des invités voici les
titres parole à nadja est candidate la
république en marche dans la 2e
circonscription originaire de trappes
est cadre dans le secteur bancaire la
jeune femme se présente pour la première
fois à une élection nous devrons avoir
avec elle et puis nous recevrons sur le
plateau ludovic salle dont le président
de la cceg des dans les yvelines et
jean-gabriel mais yat le responsable
outils plaidoyer à la ccfd en vue des
élections législatives l'organisme a
décidé de se faire entendre en avançant
15 propositions sociales emmanuel macron
est le nouveau président de la
république on aurait pu croire que la
politique s'arrêterait là
mais elle reprend ses droits avec les
législatives qui se déroulent au mois de
juin
nous recevons ce soir nadia est
candidate en marche sur la 11e
circonscription excusez-moi bonsoir
bonsoir
alors c'est votre première élection
pourquoi avoir décidé de vous présenter
eh bien écoutez mode pour commencer
je suis issu de la société civile donc
je n'ai jamais candidate et pour preuve
aucun mandat j'ai décidé aujourd'hui de
deux engagés puisque je pense que les
choses doivent donc changer on a besoin
de renouvellement dans la sphère
politique et on doit avoir des
personnalités de terrain pour pouvoir
changer les choses
alors pourquoi cette circonscription je
sais que vous êtes originaire de trappes
ce sera fait je suis originaire de
trappes
j'ai vécu donc j'y suis né j'y ai grandi
j'y ai vécu jusqu'à l'âge de 27 ans j'ai
obtenu mes diplômes dont sept dans cette
circonscription et j'ai décidé de
m'engager à trappes puisque je connais
les difficultés que la circonscription
connaît puisque j'ai moi même été
confronté
et donc je compte bien aujourd'hui
accomplir une mission d'accompagnement
et améliorer la vie locale dont a besoin
de nos concitoyens certains de vos
concurrents disent que je ne vous
connais pas à trappes
comment vous allez réussir à vous
imposer alors certains le disent donc
mais en tout cas très peu dans les
attrape en tout cas ne me connaissent
pas donc j'ai des choses à voir pour
bien écouter j'ai fait j'ai j'ai vécu
donc je pense que c'est déjà une très
bonne chose
j'ai vécu je connais les difficultés que
rencontrent les jeunes puisque moi-même
je les ai rencontrés et je ne compte pas
forcément m'imposer je compte tout
simplement travailler et travailler en
collaboration avec les citoyens de la
circonscription pour encore une fois
améliorer leurs conditions de vie qui se
dégrade
année après année mandat après mandat et
il est tout juste le temps que ça change
alors on va en parler c'est une
circonscription assez compliqué le
député sortant c'est benoît hamon il
parti socialiste on a aussi jean michel
fourgous qui était l'ancien député
qu'est-ce que vous concrètement vous
allez faire sur cette circonscription
et bien moi j'ai cinq priorités pour
cette circonscription donc qui sont
l'éducation la jeunesse l'emploi la
sécurité et le vivre ensemble
mais vous avez vous pouvez développer
certaines de ses hésitations donc
promouvoir la jeunesse par exemple
prenons alors un mot d'ordre pour la
jeunesse c'est agir pour et avec la
jeunesse
il attend aujourd'hui de dire stop à
tous ceux qui souhaitent décider et agir
à la place des jeunes c'est aux jeunes
de prendre leur destin en main c'est à
eux que revient la tâche de décider pour
leur avenir
je compte aujourd'hui créer une plate
forme citoyenne dans lequel les jeunes
vous ce se mobiliser pour répondre pour
apporter des propositions sur leur
situation
j'étais moi-même jeunes dans cette
circonscription j'étais frustré qu'on
agisse et qu'on décide à ma place donc
aujourd'hui il est juste temps de dire
stop aux jeunes de prendre leur avenir
en main et avec cette plateforme
citoyenne je souhaite avoir la force de
pouvoir évoquer la problématique liée à
la jeunesse
j'aimerais qu'on passe à la sécurité
vous êtes au fait de l'actualité
dernièrement il y à une personne qui a
tué enfin qui a tiré sur plusieurs
personnes attrapent dont un mort près
d'un burger king vous au niveau de la
sécurité
qu'est ce que vous feriez ce que cette
abeille court toujours alors très
concrètement ce ce crime qui équipe ses
sept succès sur de crime qui a lieu
aujourd'hui à trappes a bien été prise
en main par le ministre de l'intérieur
gérard collomb qui s'est déplacé à
trappes pour prendre au sérieux ce
dossier là donc de mon côté de mon point
de vue c'est tout simplement le
programme d' emmanuel macron qui doit
être mis en avant
c'est une tolérance l'osi
2h00 sur tous les crimes et les
incivilités qui doivent être sanctionnés
aujourd'hui pour vous bien la ville on
peut passer pour la en ce moment le
couteau on voit très concrètement le
résultat de sa politique mais les ya
cinq ans dans la circonscription donc
une dernière question comme ça on le
sait à trappes
il y a des problèmes avec lili à des
réseaux jihadistes ont très clairement
plusieurs jeunes sont partis on le sait
qu'est-ce que vous concrètement vous
allez faire pour ça et emmanuel ma point
souvent été critiqué par rapport à
osselle ses idées face à la lutte contre
le terrorisme
oh vous serez sur cette circonscription
alors emmanuel macron il ya répondu en
criant enfin il a l'intention de créer
une cellule qui lui rapportera
directement pour traiter des problèmes
du terrorisme demain côté effectivement
c'est un problème qui doit être pris au
sérieux et il y a est ce là plusieurs
choses que nous pouvons mettre en place
je pense qu'il faut commencer déjà par
par la prévention il faut prévenir nos
jeunes du danger lié au radicalisme dans
un premier temps est doux et du
jihadisme de dans un second temps il y
avait effectivement aussi une travail de
deuil
nous devons aujourd'hui participer à
l'amélioration de nos systèmes
d'information et enfin pour finir une
vigilance en une vigilance accrue pour
être beaucoup plus alerte sur les
signaux qui nous qui sont détectés
aujourd'hui et bien je vous remercie en
aide avec nous mais ce que l'on reste
sur le sujet des législatives alors
l'assiette ccfd terre solidaire le
second pour le secours catholique oxfam
et peuples solidaires ont décidé en vue
des élections législatives de se faire
entendre en avançant 15 propositions
sociales pourra parler nous recevons
monsieur ludovic salvo président ccfd
et jean gabriel mailhac responsable du
plaidoyer ccfd
vous les connaissez tu peux j'ai lu un
article effectivement les concernant et
il est question qu'on se rencontre très
prochainement et bien sens très bien
alors dites moi pourquoi avoir nous en
place ces quinze propositions sociales
et bien disons que les législatives sont
un moment tout à fait privilégiée pour
les organisations qui luttent contre les
injustices et la pauvreté en particulier
celles qui y sont liées au
sous-développement de prendre la parole
et pour cela il est effectivement
nécessaire de faire bouger la loi et
c'est donc le bon moment pour nous de
nous adresser à ceux qui vont
effectivement rédigé la loi alors quel
est le postulat il ya vraiment plus de
pauvreté
la cdc c'est un moment important vous
fait faire ça si dès lors la fois que
vous faites sader non c'est pas la
première fois
tout à fait il y à il ya de la pauvreté
effectivement dans nos dans nos pays
riches et il y a de la pauvreté dans les
pays pauvres et il y à un certain nombre
de mécanismes qui font que cette
pauvreté là au lieu de diminuer l empire
alors elles sont basées sur quoi qu'est
ce que vous mettez la en avant et qu'est
ce que les candidats devront accepter
parce que c'est le but du jeu le but du
juste c'est effectivement d'avoir un
dialogue avec les candidats dans le
perspective évidemment de la
constitution du nouveau parlement et de
leur demander de s'engager de s'engager
d'une part par conviction de s'engager
d'autre part parce que l'opinion
publique est aussi favorable à un
certain nombre de décisions qui doivent
être prises par exemple concernant les
paradis fiscaux par dre par exemple
concernant toutes les formes d'évasion
fiscale par exemple concernant le rôle
des entreprises des multinationales
notamment qui interviennent dans les
pays du tiers monde
à partir de cette pauvreté du
tiers-monde qui existe et qu'on n'a pas
inventé qui malheureusement ne va pas
s'arrêter demain
à partir de cela nous avons fait le
constat que il fallait faire bouger
l'ensemble du système il fallait faire
bouger les lignes et faire bouger les
lignes ça passe par de nombreux
mécanismes mais ça passe aussi par
l'évolution des lois des règlements des
procédures concrètement de trois thèmes
principaux sur lesquels nous travaillons
nous faisons ces propositions aux
candidats c'est d'une part
le thème du partage des richesses pour
la réduction des inégalités c'est
deuxièmement la prise de conscience que
la crise climatique que l'on commence
seulement à connaître à des conséquences
il y aura des conséquences de plus en
plus grave sur le développement de
l'agriculture et par conséquent sur les
capacités des peuples notamment du tiers
monde à se nourrir
d'où la grande question de la faim qui
n'est pas éradiquer la faim faille m
et puis troisièmement c'est la question
des droits des droits humains des droits
environnementaux qui doivent se
développer partout dans le monde
il voulait bien que sur ces trois thèmes
là cela concerne aussi bien ce qui peut
se passer dans les pays du tiers-monde
qui et je dirai l'origine de la raison
d'être du ccfd mais également les pays
développés la france en particulier avec
la turquie le reste on va prendre une de
vos propositions la proposition le
roccat stopper tout risque de nouvelle
crise financière et réguler
drastiquement la finance en la remettant
au service de l'économie réelle
concrètement vous faites comment tu te
fais alors il est c'est un secret pour
personne que la finance travaillent pour
elle et pas vraiment pour l'économie
réelle et donc les propositions qui sont
faites c'est effectivement une vraie
séparation bancaires entre la banque de
crédit la banque de dépôt et de crédit
d'une part et d'autre part l'aspect
spéculatif des banques qui engendre un
risque absolument énorme pour le système
bancaire est porté pour l'économie c'est
et donc ça c'est pour la séparation
bancaire et c'est aussi la mise en place
d'une taxation sur les transactions
financières dont on parle depuis des
années et qui n'est toujours pas là dont
le résultat dont le rôle dans le
résultat de cette taxation permettrait
de financer le le changement climatique
le changement climatique
d'une part et les objectifs du
développement durable et c'est bien vous
vous parler parce qu'on va rester sur
cet axe là parce que cette semaine
c'était un sujet d'actualité il ya
plusieurs pays qui freinent des quatre
fers
belgique etc et emmanuel matteau qui
vient d'être en poste devait aussi
répondre à cette fameuse taxation
qu'est ce que vous vous en pensez je
crois que il va falloir y réfléchir
cette annonce est un sujet qui doit être
qui doit être étudié analysé taxes et
des transactions financières n'est pas
si simple
et le sujet doit être étudié ok très
bien
vous devez les rencontrer incessamment
sous peu de lieux les dates pour choeur
il ya plusieurs enfants talent nous
rencontrons nous essayer de rencontrer
les disponibilités des uns et des autres
n'est pas évidente mission de rencontrer
des candidats en tout quatre les
principaux candidats aux élections
législatives et nous demandons très
concrètement de s'engager le s'engager
sur les 15 propositions que nous
présentons pour que dans l'avenir on
puisse effectivement mobilisés à la fois
je me disais l'opinion publique et les
forces politiques et les forces
institutionnelles pour cela concrètement
il y aura aussi des réunions publiques
avec les candidats c'est le cas
notamment dans la 2e circonscription des
yvelines
celle où nous nous trouvons actuellement
qui regroupe une partie de versailles le
lisier la vallée de chevreuse
il y aura le 31 mai prochain à
l'université interâges de versailles à
20h30 le soir une réunion publique avec
5 candidats candidat des républicains le
candidat de dents marche un candidat
divers droite candidat d'europe écologie
les verts est un candidat de la france
est soumise est la question que nous
demandons de développer c'est la
fraternité un enjeu pour la france dans
le monde et c'est sur ce dernier mot
qu'on va refaire merci de l'émission
merci d'être venue dans l'émission cette
ut les invités et nous on se retrouve
demain
bones
[Musique]